hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the 6th edition of the
Sun way CGS tournament it's Vassili when
Chuck versus pregnan anda now the the
tournament is three hundred and eleven
and eleven players and this is a game
from round six it's it's really a wild
game so I do hope you enjoy it now
without further ado let's check out the
game as a lot of you have requested it
so with the white pieces chalky opens
with E for now we have c5 progress for
the Sicilian defense night of three
nights the c6 and now waiting with the
d4 first Knight to c3 with d6 by Prague
and d4 now now striking in the center
seek after snide captures and Knight to
f6 and here
chalky goes for the sozin and with the
bishop the c-4 Fischer's favorite weapon
with Queen to b6 now immediately
challenging the knight in the center and
here we have Knight d2 b5
now we have a 6 Prager pushes the knight
back and but first Bishop to e3
attacking the Queen we have Queen back
to a5 and the now Knight back to d4 with
east 6 by Prague and Chucky's just
castles Bishop to e7 probably bears the
castle and Bishop to b3 now the bishop
is just much safer there and now comes
Knight captures on d4 now it's not a new
move it has been played before it's just
a castling is almost always played here
but even though it's a it's a rather an
online it hasn't been played and talk to
your tournaments since 2017 but ok
Knight capture son before we have Bishop
captures and here b5 is an on move in
the position but here Prague castles
with the King and it is as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
Chuck continues with Queen to d3
develops the Queen connects the rooks
with b5 now preparing b4 to put more
pressure on the e4 pawn with a3
preventing that and then out Bishop to
be 7 and here f4 just continuing to
expand f5 will be an idea in the future
since the light square bishop is so
conveniently placed on the this long
diagonal we have rook a to C 8 and King
to 8
one now always useful move most of the
times we have Queen back to DA the queen
is somewhat misplaced here if you look
at the Chucky's bishop pair here it's
really just a beautiful blush a pair so
proud the end the Queen doesn't really
do anything on a5 so Queen back to d8
and now rook 81 with a lot of with
really flexible play here are chalky can
double rooks on the air file he can
double rooks on the e-file he can do
some nice rook lifting it this way he
can do some nice rock lifting this way a
lot of rook lifting the ideas rook to e8
preparing Bishop to f8 the bishop will
help out with the defense while the rook
will gain control of the e-file we have
looked at eetu not with ideas like I
said of either doubling here doubling
here but also it will just nicely
support to the second ring as well with
Bishop to f8 by Prague oh and the now
Queen to h3 and now bringing the Queen
to uh add to a much deadlier square and
as we always say when you play the
Sicilian you want to execute d5 as soon
as possible and here as Chuckie allows
that Prague will execute its d5 of
course Chucky wants to attack on the
King side so as the principle goes if
you want to attack on the King side you
don't want to open up the center so II
five and now tonight's the efore or
offering some trades but Chucky
continues his expansion on the Kings
side would f5 f6 is coming now of course
if you capture and capture there's just
too much pressure the f7 is threatened
you you can't really do anything with
the Queen since you also have to keep an
eye on the d5 pawn and it was just it
would just be terrible for black so
after a 5 we have Knights to c5 now the
night also guards these its pawn but
also you can just eliminate one of our
white strong pieces with f6 by chalky
and now just Knight characters on b3
eliminating the lights work but so we
have C capture some B 3 and then now a5
preparing before but also if nightcap
person B 5 then Prague who has a bishop
to a6 in mind at the try and trade off
as many pieces as possible because the
knight will be a strong attacker of the
King side so chalky not interested in
Knight captures he goes rook to e3
better bring another
into the attack with b4 and now
attacking the knight and now just F
captures on g7 so what can you do here
Prague of course captures Bishop capers
on g7 and now rook the g3 Chucky's
offers the night here but it's really
not a peace offer because even if you
capture you just get Queen to h6
threatening mate and after King f8
there's no way to defend the mate you
have to start running away with the King
but you will not be successful just
being captors and g7 King is 7 and now
Queen captures on f7 will be made so
after rook to g3 we have rook to e7
and now the Queen can reach f8 to help
out with the defense of the bishop here
but now again Chucky's brings another
rook into the attack with rook to f4 so
a second rook lifts and a very nice one
at that we have B captures on c3 there
are no better moves than this so C
capture son B 3 but now Queen to h6 now
threatening mate here Queen to f8 by
Prague and believe it or not even though
it's on only move 28 Sharkey has a
forced mate in 5 here so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
mate in five while I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such a nice mate in 5a glad it's not
matin aid that we have too much rhymes
as it is on this channel and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook to h4 and there is nothing
black can do here so Queen captures on
h7 is the maid threat only good movies
f6 for a 5a Prague played f5 but now
comes Queen captures on h7 with check
King to f7 now Queen to g6 with check
King to g8 and now Chucky just played
rook G to h3 and it was in this position
that the progress on the game as there
is nothing he can do here whatever any
move black does its mate in one
so whatever you do let's say you play
Queen f7 try and create some escape
route for your king
rook the h8 is the main threat because
the bishop is pinned you will not be
able to have to survive this any other
move also just rook to e8 will be mated
there is no avoiding that and still
still
still the mate is you know delivered on
h8 and again we have the rhyme so yeah
it's unavoidable but yeah yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said again from round six but after six
rounds it is in fact Anton Cordova who
is leading the tournament he's six out
of six and in round seven he will face
none other than Vasily even Chuck so
it's gonna be a wild round seven Sharkey
versus horrible
so we if it's gonna be at least a little
bit interesting we will cover that so
there we have it Bravo had a brilliant
here and he could still have a brilliant
tournament but when you face chalky you
know just anything can happen
so once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank expanding your world
and the borescope and for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix plus we're gonna check up on
the sound we see just tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course wood whatever
else happens in the chess world and
expect the chess manga update fairly
soon so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day